Speaker 1: Donald Trump wants to hire radical
right wing activists. Laura Loomer to his 2024
campaign staff. And Loomer is such a nutty person
that even radical, repugnant Marjorie Taylor
GREENE is trying to get in the way of her hiring.
Trump has told aides that he wants to hire Loomer.
This is coming to us from a report from the New
York Times through four anonymous sources. The
Times says that Donald Trump met with Ms.. Loomer
recently and directed advisers to give her a role
in support of his candidacy. Loomer was part of
the peanut gallery that was at Trump's post-arrest
speech in Mar a Lago last week. Of course, the
Trump campaign staff is not happy with the idea
of hiring Loomer, and that prompted her to send
out the message saying, quote, The president knows
I have always been a Trump loyalist and that
I'm committed to helping him win reelection in
2024. He likes me very much, and it's a shame that
he's surrounded by some people that run through a
publication that is notorious for attacking him
in order to try to cut me at the knees instead
of being loyal to President Trump and respecting
their confidentiality agreements. She also said,
I know a lot of people don't like me, and that's
their problem, not mine. I have proven my loyalty
to President Trump countless times over, and even
if other people try to malign me and undermine
President Trump's wishes, I will continue to be
a ride or die Trump supporter. Trump deserves
loyalty, and he deserves to have loyal people
working for him who do not leaked to the press.
To give you a picture as to who Laura Loomer
is, she is mainly known for her far right and
anti-Muslim activism. In November 2018, she was
banned from Twitter for violating the platform's
rules against hate speech. She had previously made
controversial comments about Muslims, including
calling for a non Islamic Uber. Those were her
words, non-Islamic. Uber. And accusing Muslims
of supporting rape. Uber and Lyft decided to ban
her from using the services over these comments.
In 2017, she appeared on a white supremacist
podcast. Loomer claims that Jewish privilege
exists in the United States and that Jews control
the media and politics. This is especially
strange for her to say because she herself
is Jewish. In 2018, Loomer showed up at the
Twitter headquarters in New York City. I remember
when this would happen. This was a wacky story,
and she handcuffed herself to the building
to protest her ban from the platform. She
also supports white nationalism and has spread
conspiracy theories about COVID 19 and the 2020
election. But much of that is just par for the
course when it comes to Republicans these days.
To give you an idea as to how nuts Loomer is,
Representative Marjorie Taylor GREENE, who, you
know, again, at least at one time believed in Cuba
and on and Jewish space lasers and thinks that
Democrats are pedophiles and wearing a mask is
somehow like the Holocaust. She tweeted about this
idea to hire Laura Loomer, saying, quote, Laura
Loomer is mentally unstable and a documented liar.
She cannot be trusted. She spent months lying
about me and attacking me just because I supported
Kevin McCarthy for speaker and after I had refused
to endorse her last election cycle. That's the
other thing. Laura Loomer did run for Congress at
least once. She loves the alleged FBI informant
and weirdo Nick Fuentes. She tried to get hired on
the campaign after the infamous Mar a Lago dinner,
but Kanye West refused to hire her. So now she's
running to Trump. Never hire or do business with a
liar. Liars are toxic and poisonous to everything
they touch. I'll make sure he knows. Okay. So
clearly, there was some personal animosity there
between Marjorie Taylor GREENE and Laura Loomer.
But even so, when you're that crazy, when you're
that far right, that conspiratorial, that bigoted,
that even Marjorie Taylor GREENE is denouncing
you in this way and trying to get in the way of
you getting hired by the Trump campaign, That
is when you know that you are just completely
off of the deep end. And Trump must be thinking,
I don't really care about that stuff because I
agree with her on a lot of these issues, namely
the 2020 election conspiracy theories. And the
most important thing to Donald Trump, after all,
is loyalty. Loomer is loyal to Trump and arguably
loyal than other people are on his campaign staff,
and so that's enough for him. It may be enough to
push him over the edge into actually deciding to
hire her. However, we've also seen Donald Trump
acquiesce to the wishes of his campaign staff and
his administration staff over the years. And so
my sense is that maybe he'll be talked out of it.
But just the fact that he was meeting with her,
speaking to her at Mar a Lago, the fact that
this idea has been floated and it's getting
this attention and he's talking to insiders about
it, that's how we know that this is a complete,
unserious person, as if we didn't already
know that already from the years and years
that we've been witnessing Donald Trump. But
that's the latest. Laura Loomer may just may
be able to find herself a job in the Donald
Trump campaign. All right. That's going to
do it for today's episode of the David Pakman
Show. It's been a pleasure filling in for David
today. I say I enjoy doing it more. More every
single time I do it. It's not the end, though,
for those of you who are members. If you go to
join Pacman dot com and sign up for a membership,
you'll be able to join me on today's bonus show
when we talk about a few more stories today.
Unidentified: To everyone
else, we'll see you next.